هناك القليل من الابتسام حول هذا
الدلافين في وسط خاركيف
صامت
جيدًا تقريبًا صفارات الإنذار تهوية تقريبًا لتحل محل
هتافات
الحشود تم إجلاء سبعة دلافين
إلى رومانيا
وأوديسا من أجل الأمان ولكن حوت شنيزجر عالق
مع رفيقها بلومبيا وهي أيضًا
كبيرة لتحريك
ماريا التي تبلغ من العمر ثلاثة أشهر وهي صغيرة جدًا ،
وهي صغيرة جدًا ، وهي دلفين رضيع ،
تحتاج إلى الرضاعة كل 15 دقيقة وتكون
في حالة تنقل عندما
تولد بعد وقت قصير من غزو روسيا الجديد
لأوكرانيا ، لقد كانت محظوظة حتى الآن
في المتوسط ​​على الأقل شخصان
قُتل أطفال في أوكرانيا
كل يوم من أيام هذه الحرب
، فر مئات الآلاف من خاركيف
التي لا تزال تعاني من القصف الروسي ،
بقي مدرب الدلافين فلاد
يعيش الآن في الموقع وهو يعتني بالحيتانيات الخمسة
في البداية ، لقد كانوا خائفين للغاية ، لقد عملت
معهم لمدة سبع سنوات  كبار السن هم مثل
طفلي ،
فنحن نبحث عن مكان أفضل
لهم نحاول إخلائهم وهي مهمة شبه
مستحيلة  الشاحنات والطائرات المتخصصة
في حوض السمك يكافح
لرعاية فناني الأداء
مع عدم وجود زوار ، هناك القليل من المال الذي
يعمل فلاد بمفرده للحفاظ على
نظام تنقية المياه يعمل على
إخلاء الحيوانات المتبقية في الوقت الحالي
.
41. توتر الحرب
وملل الأسر بسبب انتباه
الزائر ،
ربما
فما رأيك في الوضع في
أوكرانيا
نقول أنه إذا لم يكن العالم
يديره رجال فلن نكون في هذا
الموقف  على الإطلاق
، كان لديهم بعض المكالمات القريبة
لقوائم السقف وحتى البركة نفسها
مثقوبة
بشظايا والآن يحذر ضباط المخابرات الأوكرانية
من هجوم روسي وشيك على
خاركيف
كل ما يمكن لهذه العائلة فعله هو البقاء على
مقربة وربما تتساءل عما إذا كان أي مكان على هذا
الكوكب  آمن
سام كيلي CNN في خاركيف